dr alexi more commonly known as just
alexi was likely born in the late 1940s
and raised in soviet russia where he
went on to become a scientist where he'd
develop a machine designed to open a
gate into an alternate realm
known as the upside down this is the
same thing that dr martin brenner was
trying to utilize 11 and mk ultra 4
two years earlier however when alexi is
abducted by jim hopper and joyce byers
he proves to be more than just a russian
scientist
alexi is an individual with his own
dreams and ambitions to become
a consumer of slurpees and burger king
two whoppers extra ketchup
large fly and one extra large
slurpee alexi is actually not alone in
his excitement over commodities from the
united states they play a direct role in
what leads to his eventual
death and no i don't mean from sugar's
fats and cholesterol of the food that
alexi likes to eat to learn more about
alexi and why his love of cherry
slurpees is actually very important
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to horror history in this lesson
i'll be covering the life and meaning of
this looney tune love and kami from the
third season of stranger things the
funny thing is
alexi's story kinda comes true in a way
for the actor that played him alec
utkoff he really did grow up in soviet
russia and although it looks like he now
resides in the uk he is kind of living
the american dream or at least
some version of it by starring in
massive american productions like jack
ryan and stranger things to fully
understand alexi i'm gonna look back at
everything he's experienced over the
course of his life his excitement over
consumerism and why his death is more
significant than you might think
as i mentioned it looks like alexi is
born in the late 1940s just judging off
his appearance this would be just
shortly after world war ii
and at this time joseph stalin put what
was referred to by winston churchill as
the iron curtain in place this
essentially cut off the soviet union
from any contact with non-communist
countries which included getting any
kind of imports including food
music toys and yes even slurpees as
winston churchill put it in his 1946
speech at westminster college in
missouri
from stephen in the baltics to trieste
in the adriatic
an iron curtain has descended across the
continent that means that alexi would
have grown up with a very strict life
under constant surveillance and
commodities of more western cultures
especially the united states would have
been things that he could only have
access to from the black market
and if he were caught enjoying these
things there would be severe
consequences
the theme of the comparison of consumer
capitalism mapped over the falling of
the soviet union is abundant in season
three of stranger things it starts with
the commentary by
erika sinclair of all people the younger
sister of lucas even though she's just a
kid she
frequently mentions her love of
capitalism know what i love
most about this country capitalism and
her dislike of communism
just because i don't agree with
communism as an ideology this is also
signified later in the season where
steve harrington is being brutally
interrogated by comrade general
stephanov and it tries to get out of it
by offering him a scoops ahoy flavor the
ss butterscotch to which stepping off
laughs in steve's face
or again later when hopper and murray
try to pass his soviet soldiers by
murray making a joke about secretly
drinking vodka while also identifying
that individualism is something to be
shamed
for
[Laughter]
alexis first introduced in 1984 as a
russian scientist working on a giant
drill in an underground bunker when the
drill backfires and eviscerates everyone
in its proximity alexi witnesses the
very darth vader-like murder of his
direct supervisor at the hands of the
dead-eyed henchman trigore
at the request of comrade general
stephanie as alexi watches this
punishment unfold he's informed that he
will have one year to fix the problems
and make the machine work assuming that
if he doesn't he will meet a similar
fate to his predecessor alexia is seen
again one year later in july of 1985
when dustin sets up his radio in an
attempt to connect with his summer
girlfriend only to accidentally
intercept a russian transmission that he
can't understand the transmission is
actually a code coming from the same
underground bunker as earlier only now
alexia and his team have made some
progress
dustin gets very concerned with
intercepting this message which is a
reflection of the fear throughout the
u.s of communism
as mentioned in an earlier episode of
horror history on the demogorgon
in season 3 however the threat of
communism in the cold war is much more
blatant even though he's a kid it makes
sense that dustin would be aware of the
danger posed by the russians because it
was evident
in the movies that were released in 1985
when the storyline takes place
it can be assumed that alexi continued
to work on the machine as if his life
depended on it but he's not seen again
until he
for some reason is in an underground
bunker of the hess family farm
with this guy that's when joyce buyers
and jim hopper break in they confront
alexia at gunpoint where it's made clear
that alexi does not speak english
i can't understand you alexi finds
himself in the middle of a scary combat
situation between hopper and gregory the
scary dead-eyed henchman who killed his
predecessor a battle which ends in alexi
being abducted by joyce and hopper
up until now alexi hasn't had much
opportunity to show any individual
personality and how could he he's had
one job to do which is to make a drill
work and his comrade general expects him
to do pretty much only that
now that he's captured by joyce and
hopper initially there's still not a ton
of room for his individual personality
to show
apart from him expressing that he may
know a better way to fix hopper's car
when it breaks down
only to be ignored as the car explodes
is until joyce and hopper get into an
argument in the woods stop paying
attention and alexia is able to make a
run for it and escape from them it seems
like alexi might have a shot of getting
away until he comes to an abrupt stop on
his own
pointing and smiling at something as
hopper catches up to him what he is
smiling at is revealed
it's a 7-eleven alexi wears an
expression that looks like a child who's
just about to enter disneyland
alexi joyce and hopper all pound back
coca-cola which by the way is not a
great choice to hydrate especially if
you've been running through the woods
without water but it's one of the many
examples in season three of stranger
things where product placement is
heavily showcased similar to the eggo
waffles in the previous two seasons the
product placement in season three is
deliberate and holds significant meaning
especially for alexi
as i mentioned earlier the rise of
american consumerism in the 1980s
is all over stranger things season 3
with the introduction of the new star
court mall
the mall is pretty much a direct symbol
of the shifting of the american dream
and the end of the cold war hawkins
small town values are being directly
threatened and altered by showing small
businesses closing as everyone clamors
to the new mall
even hopper's wardrobe changes stranger
things is known for its nostalgia for
movies of the early 1980s but the star
court mall allows for a new type of 80s
nostalgia this is towards the fashion
styles music and products from this time
period this even includes a lighthearted
chopping montage with 11 and max to
madonna's material girl similar to some
commercials of that era
as always the show pays a very accurate
tribute to the logos and ad campaigns
from this time even going so far as to
include the big fail that was new coke
by having lucas try to compare new coke
to john carpenter's the thing
it's like carpenter is the thing the
original is the classic
no question about it but the remake
[Music]
sweeter bolder
better you're insane i wasn't around for
new coke but the thing
pretty good but what does any of this
have to do with alexis it's revealed
that the starcourt mall is actually a
front for the secret russian operation
several miles beneath the mall hopper
and
commandeer a cadillac el dorado
convertible from this
very 1980s guy then they bring alexi to
the only person that they know who
speaks russian who naturally is murray
baum
now having a translator english-speaking
audiences such as myself
and 99 of you get to experience alexi's
personality for the first time
we learned that he loves looney tunes
burger king and is passionate about
cherry slurpies
roll the clip
[Music]
he respectfully disagrees shortly after
this alexia is released with the keys to
the convertible he's visibly thrilled at
the idea of taking this luxury american
vehicle for a joyride he gets behind the
wheel floors it and just when he seems
like he's going to leave his captors
behind he makes the surprising choice to
stop
turn around and go back to join them he
even concedes that a strawberry slurpee
tastes just the same as cherry
they make a pit stop at hawkins fourth
of july carnival and it is here that
alexi reveals to murray how badly he
wants to enjoy western commodities by
asking
yesterday
murray very directly addresses what the
american dream would appear to be to
alexi
by saying
[Music]
demeanor is often almost child like he
loves sweets he asks repeatedly if he
can watch looney tunes even when he
plays darts at the carnival he's
surrounded by children who cheer for him
as if he's just another child this
actually makes a lot of sense when you
consider alexi's background and what
many russian citizens were experiencing
during this time period
in 1985 the year that stranger things
season 3 takes place mikhail
gorbachev had come to power in the
soviet union with the goal to
democratize the ussr where stalin had
put up an iron curtain gorbachev
promoted new policies of glasnost and
perestroika or openness and
restructuring
ronald reagan and gorbachev signed a
culture agreement through geneva in
order to open communication with the
west and it's thanks to this that we now
have the internet video of billy joel
having a breakdown on stage
what does billy joel flipping over his
piano while his band continues to rock
out have to do with alexi
this billy joel performance was part of
a huge tour across the ussr
in 1987. this tour was a very big deal
in opening communication between the
united states and soviet countries while
other singers and rock stars had
performed in small venues in the ussr
billy joel was the first to do a large
amphitheater style rock show and
naturally there was a lot of pressure on
him as billy performs he can be heard
yelling at his camera crew to stop
lighting the audience
what was happening was there were
filmmakers working on a documentary
about the tour they wanted to get
footage of the russian audience enjoying
the show but every time the lights would
come up in the crowd the audience would
completely freeze
this was because they like alexi had
grown up under strict communist
surveillance where enjoying western
culture was illegal and considered a
betrayal
there may have been new leadership in
place but openly enjoying something like
this was still kind of taboo so alexi
openly enjoying looney tunes burger king
slurpees and carnival games would be
something he likely wouldn't be
comfortable doing in front of his
russian superiors
especially considering that the guy in
charge wasn't exactly all about fun and
games
so when lexi wins the carnival dart game
and shows off his giant woody woodpecker
prize with a huge smile on his face it
means so much more to him than what we
see on the surface
alexi like many other russians missed
out on consumerism as a child and is now
making up for lost time which makes it
all the more crushing when he sees a
grigori appear when grigory whispers
traitor to alexi as he passes him after
shooting him in the chest it isn't just
because alexi was helping hopper joyce
and murray in stopping the russians from
opening the upside down but also because
alexi's enjoyment of american culture
was seen as a direct betrayal of his
soviet regime maybe it's because of this
that alexi's death
even though he's just more of a
secondary protagonist hurts so much or
maybe it's because of his new best
friendship with murray
either way watching alexi die is one of
the many tragic losses that takes place
in stranger things
season three i just left for a minute
for a corn dog stupid corn dog
don't leave for a corn dog stay here and
check out another episode of horror
history
just click that video on the left and
let me know what other stranger things
characters you'd like to see me cover
make sure you show your love of american
culture by subscribing to sisi's world
for new horrors every week
ring that death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive